家から徒歩
1分の時販機です
はじ）もう折れちゃってるからね
はじ）やべーなこれ
はじ）え？これゼロ円？？え待って、え？ゼロ？へ？
はじ）110円のやつか
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
うちの家の近くに、この自販機があるんですけれど
使う人が非常に限られております たまに使うぐらいでしょ？
たく）たまに両替で使っている
両替で使うのね
でも、見てくださいよ、100円が切れてるんですよ。
これは非常に由々しき事態だ
誰がこれを補充するのか
俺しかいないだろ
今日はこの自販機に100円を何円か入れてって
釣り切れの100円をなくしていきたいと思うんですけども
こちらに僕は目をつけた訳でございます
買ったら数字がテュルテュッテュテュウって4桁出るんですけど
7が4つ揃ったらもう1本プレゼントと書いてあるんですけども
これ当たった人見たことないんすよ
ここで買う人が限られているという現実
100円玉が入っていない
あたりがでるかわからない ということで
よーし では、回していきます
たく）ガチャみたいにいうやん
はじ）もうやば、もう色褪せすぎじゃね？だって
たく）色褪せてるよ
はじ）いきます
はじ）もう8の時点でダメじゃん
もう無理なんだって、無理なんだって
たく）88まできたからあと10分の1だよ
と、思うじゃん？7777じゃないと駄目なんだよ
じゃあ、2回目いきます　はいっ！
はじ）もう6の時点で駄目だもん　お？
はじ）そうなんだよ
3回目((はいっ
はじ）もう6の時点で無理だもん、絶対
はじ）ほらね
だって俺出たことないしこれだって
4回目いきます
はじ）もう5の時点で、、、
ほら、この毎回ドキドキさせるパターンが
どうしようもn
5回目いきます
はじ）ああ、もう無理だ　もう無理だ
はじ）もう3とか無理じゃん、絶対
6回やったんですけど、出る気配がありません
これさあ
これ出ない気がする
出ないよ多分、出ないよ
やるけど
7回目いきます
はじ）そろそろ、売り切れの100円がなくなってもいい時期だと思うんだが
チッ　8本目いきます
はじ）もう4の時点でさぁ無理でしょ、ねぇ
たく）惜しいんでだよね、44、、、
9本目いきます
はじ）もう8の時点で、だってさあ、、、
たく）あ？あ！あっ！！
はじ）え？え！えっ！！
はじ）あ！あっ！！
やったあ
俺がこの自販機を救ったと言っても過言ではない
たく）間違いない
とりあえずこの自販機は正常に戻りました
たく）あれ？ライトついた
夜です！！
10本目いきます
はじ）頼む、頼む、頼む
はじ）あっ？あっ？あっ？待って！待って！！待って待って
あっ！あっ！きた！きたきた！！やった！やったあ！！
たく）一番いいの選ぼう
はじ）一番いいの！！どれだ
はじ）これでいい！？いい！？
バウバウダアアアアア！！！